... Hi there,  Steve Kaufmann here,
and today I want talk about French
pronouns, my favorite French pronouns.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
uh, and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So why am I talking about French pronouns?
Well, I was thinking the other day
about what I enjoy about different
languages and what I think makes me
feel comfortable, natural, native-like
in speaking these languages, it's
not the use of slang because slang
can vary from region to region.
Uh, very often it's not appropriate
to use slang unless you're really
comfortable or until you're at a
stage where you're confident that,
that you can use it and it's gonna be
appropriate in a particular situation.
And if you are that way,
please go ahead and use it.
I am perhaps conservative,
my age, whatever.
However, what I find really works
well in different languages.
There are usually sort of these little
details that make your language more
native-like more elegant and make you
feel more comfortable in the language.
So you know that I focus on input.
The language has to come into you,
lots of reading and listening.
However, there is that a certain amount of
time that we should spend, in my opinion,
on some of the details of the language.
I've spoken about this before.
So when it comes to French, I
happen to like two French pronouns
...
Okay.
Now, pronouns, there's lots of
pronouns in French, they work
differently than in English.
French has gender, so, uh, you know,
you've got a pronoun for ... first of
all, our, our main pronouns is sort of
as a subject of a sentence ... they're,
you know, the most common ones.
Then we have the pronouns, you
know, when it's a direct object
and then an indirect object.
And even there it varies, you know, ... I
give it to her ... there's no ... and
these are all things well worth learning.
So like it's a demonstrative pronoun
... but none of those are my favorite.
My favorites are ...and I've even done
a little lesson in LingQ about ... and
I'm gonna show you a brief walkthrough
of this lesson before I go any further.
And so that for those of you who are
studying French, you can see how I've
composed a little lesson using only
... and I'm gonna go through saving words
and phrases from that little lesson.
So here I am in my French page on LingQ.
I just uploaded a lesson ... so I click
on this and I open it up and we will
go back to the beginning and you'll see
...
...that's not the pronoun
that's in French, but ... so
you could save that as a phrase.
There are many pronouns ... you need
that all the time ... are there any?
... are there many?
Okay ... there's another one.
You can grab that ... uh,
... what do you think?
What do you think of it?
Okay, so all I'm suggesting is I
would recommend that you go to this
lesson ... and you will see lots of
examples of, you know ... I'm not
afraid of him ... I even need it.
Uh, so, uh
...
which is a very good phrase
while I think about it.
... I'm going right now.
Okay, so I just use this example
of a lesson that I created to
illustrate how useful the ... are,
it makes your French more elegant.
And I suggest that when you
come across ... in your reading
at LingQ, that wherever you...
and unless maybe you're already quite
proficient at using these two little
pronouns, um, please save them all right.
Now, you have seen the lesson, uh, you've
been exposed a bit to ...let me explain
... basically means to a place, to a thing,
... and it also sometimes can mean of it.
So ... normally is of it or
about it ... I have a lot of it.
Uh, ... I'm afraid  of it.
Uh, ... I need of it.
... and then we can combine the two.
And ... there are some ... So it's
not a big deal, but it's different
from what we do in English.
There are other handy pronouns in French.
I was thinking for example,
of the word ...which I don't
know, it sometimes translate...
translates into English as one ... one
could imagine ... but ... often means we
...
... so it can mean like we, but it
can also mean they, it's kind
of like a substitute on, uh,
...
which interestingly enough reminds
me of, so ... people say, They
say, ... can also mean we, and I was
struck when I was in Brazil because
in Brazil, the in French, or at least
in Spanish, you say ... is the people.
And I always thought ... like in
Brazil you say ... meant the people
like them, third person, but it
doesn't, it means we in Brazil.
So it's interesting how these in
French ... which can mean we, can
mean one, can mean they in different
structures, but ... is not my favorite.
Okay.
I just mentioned that in passing
because I thought of the connection
to the Brazilian use of ... but
...
if you can get good at using those two
little French words, I think you're gonna
find that your comfort level in French and
the comfort level of people listening to
you, uh, is going to take a step forward.
So a small item, I thought it might
be of interest to those of you
who are interested in French, you
know, And, uh, just a last thought.
Uh, you might find it interesting to look
at a video that I did uh, not too long
ago where I talked about difficulties
in learning French and another one where
I talked about how I learned French.
So particularly if you have thought
about learning French, you might
find these two videos useful.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.